salve a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo lo video sono pochi j
sarà diffuso come sempre questa rubrica
dei dieci minuti in cui devo riuscire a
fare più livelli possibili mancava
ovviamente penso il livello standard di
happy meals perché comunque o sono gli
impossible o sono gli smart livelli
proprio quelli classici del 10 mammamia
credono sports.ru sia proprio padre dei
livelli di è più di screening mancava il
fai più smart rock e riesci i dieci
minuti vi sfido che avete a fare meglio
di me però ho fatto soft by rating
ovviamente per i più votati del mondo di
sempre su oltre i dieci minuti piatti ci
sia un ragazzo è il primo e spero sia
easy perché sono parte che sono i reali
sul trono e che cambiano molto la loro
lati cambia colore cambia tipo la
difficoltà si il numero di personaggi
però risulta sono tutti molto se milione
tipo come i rock swing che cambiano
questo è lo sport più votato del mondo e
non so perché uguale agli altri prova
be1 anche questo v2 marcava casi due
magari aspetta bellissimo cava dove
ricevettero cerca di non farmi lanciare
il no devo farmi lanciare altre spalle
ragazzi sta sfida qua è una sfida
maledetta perché se sbagli iniziare da
zero ti fa perdere un sacco di tempo
quindi un casino due molto bene vai vai
vai così sono carico tutti tanto la fra
tutti la stessa persona
tutti e sono tutti uguali cioè il lease
ward trovo più votati del mondo sono
tutti uguali
cambia il colore di sfondo alla gara con
me come com'è possibile come possibile
che gli small troppi votati del mondo
come possibile che cambi solo il colore
è assurdo comunque 3 ma guarda era
uguale e grigio è uguale mai grigio ma
come tutti identici vabbè fino al fine
che sono cosi ma passano colpire solo
quello per vincerlo che va bene 4 questo
quale ha fatta un'altra persona sarà
diverso rispetto ai ma ora siamo a 4
larga ottima ottimo risultato con le
difficilissimo quelle difficilissimo
aspetta aspetta spettacolo
l'ho preso incredibile 5 meraviglioso
vai sull'a14 buy
poi ovviamente quando faccio sti video
poi sbaglio sempre a contare in data
magari siamo a 8
non so contare però vabbè tanto poi alla
fine facciano recato quindi fa niente
tre spade due killers due spade nakheel
una squadra dorica voi che vi dico
questo tempo borgo e questo è il
problema di risorse se tu sbagli una
volta verdi un tempo incredibile
porca vacca morta quindi l'importante
cerca di beccare sempre quella che ti dà
più spade e così a meno di più
possibilità ce la fai a prendere questa
qua ok bravo ancora quanto dura cosa
doveva salinello anzitutto ma dai non
vale bataille un file ce ne sono due in
uno quali fa perdere tempo e che poi ci
manca solo che perdo non ragazzi non ci
credo
no uk fai schifo dai dai no non è vero
non è vero orco demonio porco dopo
beccare quello rientro per avere più
spade porca vacca non ho beccato uk
prima di beccare lui e quindi tutto sono
ma va a cagare va c'è ma dio
dai dai
bravo bravo che sette minuti ma vengono
cioè va bene una sega perché poteva
essere molto più avanti prova bene suo
livello e maledetto ragazzi cioè devi
farne due in uno non vale che la porca
vacca meno un checkpoint ti vuoi
togliere la liuc bravo complimenti con è
morto quindi spade e perfetto lo
incastrare tutte male come ho fatto
come ho fatto perché come è possibile va
bene come una spalla lo becca tv6 e
questo è il settimo vaio sono sei
vediamo se riesco a fare
in attacco la palla a due è però vabbè
se ne frega dai ma cosa è successo ma
che non aveva pulito
pepe 7 sta andando forte non vale un
milione scaricare aventi l'obiettivo
regolamenti bye bye porca vacca utility
sono stati mi hanno rallentato un sacco
non è presa 26 spade dai porca vacca
roma sembra facile fare riscontro ma
fidatevi non è semplice
ok ok non è vero
tua madre è morta ieri ok va bene ok
proposta di sopra perfetto che basta e
non fatevi 26 livelli di volta 98123
poteva racconto dopo 8 ovunque più o
meno dovrei essere otto non sono più
contare
mi sono ammazzato da solo quindi molto
bene ok è partito un arpione non ho
capito prova fa niente ok aiuto vola
jane bolam spade cose ho vinto
e vabbè no no non ho capito che succeda
fa niente 95 minuti quindi se l'esca
arrivare a 10 se scriverà 10 prima dello
scoccare dei cinque minuti e sono
esattamente a metà video ne ho fatte 10
15 20 è fattibile se non la lento ok ma
vedi che c'è un'altra parte
porco demonio sti dop i livelli quanto
vi ammazzerei ma perché ma farne uno non
sa che questi valgono 2 dai a porca
vacca due livelli loro ma come aveva
fatto perdere tempo sono 455 a quest'ora
avevo già fatto ed eravamo a metà esatta
con dieci livelli vabbè fa niente ce
l'ho fatta avanti 10 ko a devo aumentare
il ritmo ragazzi se vuoi veramente
bellissimo bellissimo non è vero ma
bloccato le spade
no io non ho parole 94 minuti ragazzi
non mi cosa che più ha fatto sono sono
11 madonna rai ho perso un sacco di
tempo solo perché questo solo perché
questo mi è caduto sulle spalle io non
ho parole
la mia vita fa schifo a smetterò di
contare perché non mi dicono che quando
siamo arrivati sinceramente mi ricordo
che quando siamo arrivati vado avanti
chi se ne frega poi conto alla fine vai
vai vai vai vai veloce feriale a 20 a 20
non so se ci arrivo non so se ci arrivo
perché non so cantare meno male che
conta giampiero in editing mamma mia
ne manca uno va bene ma c'è una tizia
dentro e dietro di me ok perfetto il 3
molto bene molto bene la parte buona
parte sono tutti uguali comunque agata
via tutti i colori abbiamo fatto tutti
tutti i colori tra l'altro miley cyrus
qualche sito herck di your wife va bene
all your wife che a me andrebbe
benissimo realtà non è che milano non so
quanto siamo questo continuando a casa e
ragga senza contare per fare per
massimizzare il punteggio va bene a
posto e ho vinto ho vinto
vabbè è pagato vinto comunque
abbiamo fatto vinto avete visto con
internet è scattata la vittoria ma era
pagato gioco perché sono stupidi
tecnicamente ho vinto questo match
questo è un machete trolling che la
apple ha poche volte l'ho fatto però va
bene un minuto e 55 ragazzi ci siamo è
così alla fine non so se sono arrivato a
20 penso di essere ton e 18 in realtà e
quindi non lo so però secondo me ci
arriviamo dai vivai quante spalle ci
sono a bettini fuori vero così ok però
una va bene ok 130 vai vai vai così vai
così perfetto
vabbè che casino molto bene mamma mia
che va beh
facciamo finta di aver visto perfetto
ciao 883 max pezzali fantastico perfetto
ok un minuto 11
questo è un pieno di gente per questo ma
fatelo spalmare spade ragazzi quando
stava male spazi giuro
se famo state faccio un casino ok no mi
ha ucciso forse se si fanno casino lele
libri pezzi di persone vinco uguale però
deve andarne 1 la sopa quindi non ci
riesce non ci riesce non ci riesce non
ci riesce o ragazzi aiuto benissimo
occhio a quello dietro ok ho fatto tutto
ho fatto due no macché excellent porca
vacca beccate excelent ma anche al 30
secondi casi ma sta dondolando quei
pezzente
ma non ci credo ho perso perché non ho
beccato la excellent pegolo dritto che
portava dondolando c'è ma che sfiga
ok porca vacca ai 13 secondi verace
[Musica]
darci che noi non ci voglio che a 8
secondi veloce veloce veloce ecco
l'excellence non ce l'ho fatta
80 secondi vediamo quando devo contare
quanto siamo e perché guarda guarda
guarda adesso adesso adesso a posto
mi raccontate uguale ragazzi prego
vediamo di contare non so se sono
arrivato a 20 lo scoprirò adesso allora
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 12 13 14 15 16 a 7
parco demonio morto se avesse aggiunto
quel quid swart rocca avevano lo smog
troppo alla fine due volte quindi
venivano 2 che c'è un livello c'erano
due è un altro c'erano due praticamente
eventi però facciamo 18 perché proprio
perché sono buono però teoricamente
livelli erano insieme fa niente spero
che il vino vi sia piaciuto a me è
piaciuto un sacco a spero di fare un
altro 10 minuti di fare almeno un 20
però porca vacca sono difficili
smartphone sembra guarda che sembrano
facili soprattutto sono difficili
iscrivetevi accadesse video è piaciuto
lasciato mi piace un commento era come
sempre signori ci vediamo al prossimo
video e da ragazzi
[Musica]